avec jean marc sylvestre journaliste
éditorialiste économique jean marc
bonjour donc améliorer les rémunérations
réaménager le temps de travail investir
massivement dans des équipements
hospitaliers est ce que ce plan va se
résumer à une question de moyens et
écoutez il faut que ce plan traite des
moyens et des rémunérations parce que
les personnels soignants ne vont pas se
contenter de ce qu'on leur a annoncé la
semaine dernière quand le président de
la république de leur promet à la fois
déprimé et des médailles bon écouter les
personnels soignants et notamment les
infirmières qui en ont bavé là pendant
plus d'un mois font grise mine
et quand le président leur répond eh
bien écoutez si vous ne voulez pas des
médailles
eh bien vous ne les prendrait pas on a
l'impression quand même qu'il s'adresse
à des enfants c'est une erreur de
communication non ce n'est pas le sujet
le sujet sont effectivement les
conditions de travail le sujet c'est
effectivement la grille des salaires les
infirmières françaises sont celles qui
en europe sont parmi les plus mal payés
le personnel soignant en général et
payer plus de 10 % de moins que la
moyenne des salaires versés en france
à titre d'information et une infirmière
qui débute dans le métier aujourd'hui
touchent 1500 euros net par mois et au
terme de sa carrière elle peut espérer
avoir 2500 euros c'est donc bien
inférieurs à la moyenne des salaires et
même si on inclue dans cette moyenne
la participation des salaires des
médecins par exemple on est toujours
parmi les moins bien servis en europe
au niveau des moyens au niveau des
effectifs en nombre d'infirmiers et de
médecins
la france aligne en gros 10 infirmières
trois médecins pour 1000 habitants
on est loin de la norvège est vraiment
le champion en europe de la suisse de
l'allemagne des états unis même du japon
et de la belgique on arrive en 8ème
position mondiale
notre équipement n'est pas à la hauteur
de notre richesse
on devrait faire beaucoup mieux et
finalement le déroulé de cette épidémie
le montrent de façon très explicite mais
ce n'est pas qu'un problème de moyens
alors non c'est effectivement pas les
problèmes noya parce que paradoxalement
nous sommes le pays au monde qui dépense
le plus d'argent dans son système de
santé par rapport à son clip on dépense
11 3% du pib
exactement comme en allemagne nous
sommes les deux pays au monde qui
dépense ont le plus par rapport
les allemands dépensent en quantité plus
parce qu'ils ont un pipe plus important
mais on dépense quand même 26 % de plus
par habitant que la moyenne en europe
alors où est le problème on dépense
beaucoup d'argent mais les moyens ne
sont pas à la disposition des soignants
mots notre problème c'est qu'on dépense
cet argent très très mal notre système
est trop centralisée avec une
bureaucratie administrative qui
absorbent plus du tiers des moyens et
qui alourdit les circuits de décision
qui pénalise les soignants d'où les
problèmes de masques par exemple d'où
les problèmes de tests d'appareillage
dont on ne sait même plus qui est
responsable des déficits ou des
défaillances
le clan de réformes et ce qu'il ne peut
pas se résumer à une enveloppe
budgétaire et bien faux crâne d'ailleurs
qu'il se résume une enveloppe budgétaire
il faudra pas il faudra surtout pas il
va falloir protéger ce budget est
évidemment parce que c'est une des
richesses française mais il va surtout
falloir le réorganiser le réadapter avec
un une décentralisation des décisions au
profit des soignants au profit des
médecins au profit des sorts qui sont
sur le terrain qui savent
deuxième condition il falloir mettre le
paquet et ça c'est très important en
france sur la prévention
l'épidémie a prouvé que nous n'étions
pas prêts on n'a pas su prévoir ce qui
allait se passer et surtout cette
épidémie a prouvé qu'elle touchait
d'abord à 80% des personnes à risque et
des personnes à risques c'est quoi en
france basse et des personnes qui
développent des pathologies qui sont en
dehors d'un don donc cardiologie obésité
etc
en gros je vais être un peu à peu en
direct les personnages et que ce sont
les gros buveurs des gros mangeur et les
gros fumeurs un ailleurs troisième point
est bien vouloir renforcer la
coopération entre le public et le privé
les personnels de l'hôpital public ont
fait un travail extraordinaire mais le
privé dont on a beaucoup parlé offert
délit il a offert du temps il a offert
du matériel de réanimation et surtout la
médecine 2
la médecine de ville les médecins nul et
les médecins de campagne on guérit
beaucoup de malades ducobu alors on
touche là à des questions très politique
très sensible quasiment idéologique
surtout surtout depuis le moment déjà
les gens merci jean marc sylvestre pour
toutes ces précisions